aquí tenemos algo interesante tenemos
aquí un anillo conductor es un anillo
cuadrado que tiene una resistencia de 2
oms
vemos que mide 2 metros por dos metros
el área de este anillo sería de 4 metros
cuadrados y vemos que está pasando un
campo magnético a través de esta
superficie definida por el anillo y
vemos que es constante es un campo
magnético constante de 5 teslas y fluye
perpendicularmente a la superficie de
este anillo lo que vamos a ver es que
durante los próximos 4 segundos y esto
va a suceder a una tasa lineal o tasa
constante veremos que el campo magnético
pasará durante estos 4 segundos de 5
teslas a 10 teslas se va a duplicar
durante estos 4 segundos y al hacerlo
vamos a tener un cambio en el flujo
veremos cuál es el cambio de flujo
durante estos 4 segundos
nuestro flujo inicial que vamos a
escribirlo por acá y en cualquier
momento que ustedes se sientan
inspirados los invito a que pausa en el
vídeo para que traten de resolver esto
por su cuenta así que nuestro flujo
inicial va a ser nuestro campo magnético
constante o podríamos decir que es el
campo magnético promedio sobre esta
superficie y como es constante pues va a
ser de 5 teslas y en ese problema nos
ayuda a que los vectores del campo
magnético son completamente
perpendiculares a la superficie definida
por este anillo de no ser así tendríamos
que buscar el componente del vector que
sea perpendicular a la superficie pero
ya lo tenemos aquí son 5 teslas o el
componente perpendicular a la superficie
promedio de nuestro campo magnético esto
lo vamos a multiplicar por el área por
nuestra superficie que es de dos metros
por dos metros o sea cuatro metros
cuadrados
y esto va a ser igual a 20 teslas metros
muy bien ahora cuál va a ser el flujo
final después de esos cuatro segundos el
flujo final bueno ahora el promedio de
nuestro campo magnético o el promedio de
la componente perpendicular al área de
este campo magnético
es de 10 teclas el área de nuestro
anillo no ha cambiado sigue siendo de 4
metros cuadrados
y esto a que va a ser igual nuestro
flujo final va a ser de 40 teclas por
metro cuadrado
y cuál es nuestro cambio en el flujo
nuestro cambio en el flujo o la
diferencia de flujo va a ser igual a
nuestro flujo final menos nuestro flujo
inicial
es igual a 40 telas por metro cuadrado
menos 20 telas por metro cuadrado es
decir igual a 20 telas por metro
cuadrado ya encontramos el cambio en el
flujo y sabemos que el cambio en el
tiempo es de 4 segundos y con todo esto
ya podemos calcular cuál fue el voltaje
inducido el voltaje que nos induce una
corriente si vemos la ley de faraday si
ustedes en la red buscan la fórmula para
la ley de faraday se encontrarán con
algo que luce así el voltaje generado es
igual a menos n bueno esto es en caso de
que no estén usando la versión con
cálculo menos n por el cambio en el
flujo menos n por el cambio en el flujo
del tafí sobre el cambio en el tiempo
del tate y como comentamos al inicio en
este problema estamos suponiendo que
tenemos una tasa de cambio constante en
nuestro flujo
así que la tasa promedio de cambio en el
flujo vamos a multiplicar la por n iv n
de hecho es el número de anillos o de
circuitos que tenemos o el número de
superficies definidas por estos anillos
este ejemplo de aquí n va a ser igual a
1 sólo tenemos un anillo eso se
simplifica así y me pueden preguntar por
qué es negativo esto nos sirve para
indicar la dirección de un vector y la
verdad yo no soy muy fanática de este
signo negativo aquí
si lo buscan en un libro de texto se
encontrarán que si no están usando
cálculos esto se debe a la ley de lens
es una forma de recordarnos que aquí
estamos usando la ley de lens y es por
eso que tenemos este signo negativo aquí
y ese signo negativo tiene sentido si
estamos analizando los vectores aquí y
si tenemos que usar alguna matemática
más sofisticada esto nos dice que el
voltaje inducido va a inducir una
corriente cuyo campo magnético inducido
va a contrarrestar el cambio en el flujo
y esto es la ley de lens aquí en lo
importante al menos para este ejemplo es
encontrar nuestro cambio en el flujo y
dividirlo entre el cambio en el tiempo
y esto a que va a ser igual pues a 20
teslas metro cuadrado que es el cambio
en el flujo dividido entre nuestro
cambio en el tiempo que es de 4 segundos
que nos va a dar y bueno si quieren
podemos poner nuestro signo negativo
aquí 20 dividido entre 4 es igual a 5
tesla por metro cuadrado por segundo y
resulta que estas unidades son 1 volt
por lo que podemos decir que estos son
menos 5 volts
digamos que tenemos un voltaje de 5
volts ahorita no vamos a tomar en cuenta
el signo negativo que va a pasar por un
circuito que tiene una resistencia de 2
ohms cuál va a ser su corriente
recordamos nuestra fórmula de iguala y
por r
o voltaje es igual a la corriente por la
resistencia o podemos decir que la
corriente es igual al voltaje dividido
entre la resistencia en este caso la
corriente inducida es 5volts me voy a
enfocar ahorita en el valor absoluto del
voltaje después veremos su dirección va
a ser dividido entre la resistencia que
es de 2 oms esto va a ser igual a 2.5
amperes ahora sabemos que la magnitud de
la corriente que va a ser inducida
conforme cambia este flujo recuerden que
esto va a ocurrir en el transcurso de
cuatro segundos conforme tengamos esta
tasa de cambio en el flujo que suponemos
está cambiando a una tasa constante y
mientras está cambiando
nosotros ya encontramos que va a inducir
una corriente de 2.5 amperes la
siguiente pregunta que debemos hacernos
y ahora si vamos a tomar en cuenta este
signo negativo nuestro recordatorio de
que debemos usar la ley del n
en qué dirección va a ir esta corriente
girada en sentido horario en el
transcurso de este cambio de flujo o irá
en sentido antihorario
para descubrirlo tenemos que usar
nuestra regla de la mano derecha tomamos
nuestra mano derecha
nuestro pulgar va a ir en la dirección
propuesta o la que suponemos va a
nuestra corriente si eligiéramos está
nuestra mano derecha estaría así una
corriente que vaya en esta dirección va
a inducir un campo magnético que se
mueve hacia acá si la corriente fuera en
esta dirección el campo magnético
inducido iría en la misma dirección que
el flujo original por lo que solo
reforzaríamos el cambio en el flujo se
agregaría al flujo e iría en la misma
dirección que el cambio de flujo
original y como lo mencionamos en el
vídeo de la ley de lenz esto solo nos
provocaría un mayor flujo que a su vez
induciría una mayor corriente sería la
fuente de una energía que viene de la
nada y que va en contra de la ley de la
conservación de la energía
y que está no va a ser la dirección de
la corriente por lo que nos damos cuenta
que la dirección de la corriente va a
ser en sentido antihorario nuestra
corriente de 2.5 amperes va a ir en esta
dirección y con eso terminamos al pensar
en nuestro cambio en el flujo y cuánto
tiempo nos lleva a realizarlo pudimos
calcular no sólo la magnitud de la
corriente sino también la orientación de
la dirección en la que fluye dicha
corriente